you're a PlayStation Plus member then
you're in luck my friend because here's
a whole bunch of free games that are
just for you this August so don't sit
through another craigslist free post I'd
rather have you download games than
potentially get murdered first up is
road not taken which is sadly not the
Robert Frost poetry simulator have been
waiting so many years for fortunately it
is a puzzle based roguelike where you
must magically levitate objects and
characters in order to solve
brain-teasing situations after a
devastating winter storm the helpless
children of road not taken have been
scattered throughout the forest and it
falls upon your magical shoulders to
reunite them with their worried parents
while avoiding danger with randomly
generated environments challenging
puzzles intimidating bosses and a highly
dynamic world that reflects their
choices in real time this rewarding game
yields an entirely unique playthrough
every time you dive in on a totally
different note Fez is a real trip in
this hyper unique indie platformer you
must shift your two dimensional
perspective around and three dimensional
environments in order to overcome higher
dimensional obstacles solve the
mysteries of fezzes world and alter your
perception of the very ground you walk
upon by now everybody knows Crysis 3 New
York City has been contained than a
giant nano dome rendering the city into
a rain forest first person shooter
sandbox for you to run amok in with a
super hunting bow plus this game is
rocking EXO suits before they were cool
looking at you titanfall choose a
stealth approach a full frontal assault
or anywhere in the between is the
situation in your personal style call
for not to mention this game as more
weapons than Hitler's Christmas list and
the excellent multiplayer will keep you
engaged long after the story runs dry
Proteus is a different game than a lot
of the titles on this list it isn't
combat oriented or action-oriented
instead the gorgeous pixelated relax
about places you in a beautiful
procedurally generated world covered in
diverse flora and fauna as you explore
the entrancing soundscapes shift tone
based on your surroundings so wander
wide and take it all in but don't expect
the norm and Proteus turn off your mind
and let the synesthetic journey envelop
you Metro Co is one of those games that
you have a blast playing but get laughed
after trying to explain a puzzle
platformer based on infographic sounds
about as fun as a calculus centric
shooter but metric 0 is actually a blast
this game forces you to explore
different approaches to its mind
tickling puzzles in order
discover the relationship between your
actions and the environment and overcome
seemingly impossible obstacles if you
could graph my enjoyment of this game
that would have a positive slope and I
hate math jokes please forgive me and
finally there's the fantastical dragon's
crown this multiplayer hack and slash
action RPG pulls a wealth of popular
elements together in an attractive
package side-scrolling beat-em-up action
RPG character growth addictive Luke
collecting a lovely hand-drawn art style
and cooperative multiplayer oh and it's
got weirdly busty anime characters if
that's your thing although you really
shouldn't be buying video games to get
that fix you know about this internet
thing they've got now right